ja vielen Dank und sie haben hier nichts
verpasst wir warten
im Moment dass eine Aktuelle Stunde
aufgerufen wird und sie sehen schon die
Außenministerin aller Lena baerbock die
diese aktuelle Stunde eröffnen wird denn
es wird darum gehen ein Signal zu senden
hier aus dem Bundestag und zwar gibt es
eine Aktuelle Stunde zu den Protesten in
Iran nach dem Tod von Massa Amini im
Iran gehen die Menschen seit Tagen auf
die Straße sie protestieren und fordern
offen viele protestierende fordern offen
das Ende der Islamischen Republik im
Iran der Auslöser war ja der Tod der
22-jährigen Mascha Amini sie war von der
Sittenpolizei wegen eines Verstoßes
gegen die strengen islamischen
Kleiderordnung festgenommen worden und
am 16 September unter ungeklärten
Umständen gestorben die Demonstranten
die sprechen ja von Polizeigewalt die
Behörden die weisen das zurück die
sicherheitskr im Iran gehen gewaltsam
gegen die Proteste vor mittlerweile
sprechen nicht
Regierungsorganisationen beispielsweise
die in Oslo ansässige Organisation Iran
Human Rights von mindestens 76 Menschen
die getötet worden sind während dieser
Proteste und tausende Menschen sollen
landesweit festgenommen worden sein und
der Konflikt um den Tod von Massa Amini
Meran der hat sich über die
Landesgrenzen hinweg sogar schon
ausgeweitet während
zu dem Thema die Demonstration also dort
andauern
meldet das Nachbarland Irak mindestens
neun Tote durch iranische Angriffe in
der Kurdenregion die Bundesregierung die
verurteilt das harte Vorgehen ihrer der
iranischen Kräfte und verurteilt auch
die iranischen Angriffe ausdrücklich
ja und die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Petra Pau
wartet jetzt noch es gab ja hier während
der letzten 10-15 Minuten diverse
Abstimmungen und jetzt sortieren sich
die Reihen hier im Plenarsaal für diese
aktuelle Stunde die aufgerufen wurde ich
kann Ihnen noch sagen dass wir im
Verlauf des Weiteren
Nachmittages hier im Bundestag auch noch
Debatten haben zum Beispiel zum
Kurzarbeitergeld aber jetzt geht es
schon los mit der aktuellen Stunde und
eben der erste Rednerin
bundesaußenministerin Annalena baerbock
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Besucherinnen und
Besucher Frauen die im gnadenlosen
Beschuss von Wasserwerfern stehen die
sich ihre Kopftücher abreißen die singen
Frauen Leben Freiheit auch wenn das
Internet jetzt abgeschaltet ist wir
sehen und wir hören diese Frauen Frauen
die sich mutig dem scheinbar so
mächtigen iranischen Sicherheitsapparat
entgegenstellen
und all die Knüppel und all das
Tränengas sind alles andere als ein
Ausdruck von Macht und Stärke aus dieser
puren Gewalt des iranischen Systems
spricht pure Furcht
der nichts
der nichts fürchten jene die mit
betäubener Gewalt regieren mehr als das
Frauen gemeinsam auf die Straße gehen
und ihre Stimme erheben und diese Stimme
lässt sich nicht einfach niederknüppeln
sie lässt sich auch nicht abschalten
indem man dem Zugang zum Internet kappt
nein diese Stimme schallt laut und weit
über Iran hinaus
es ist auch die Stimme von maserhamini
aminis Familie rief Maser bei ihrem
kurdischen Namen Gina es heißt leben
auf ihren Grabstein haben ihre Eltern
schreiben lassen ich zitiere du bist
nicht gestorben
dein Name ist ein Aufruf
und diesem Aufruf folgen so viele im
Netz auf der Straße gestern in Berlin
danke
und wir folgen ihnen heute hier im
Deutschen Bundestag mit den politischen
Mitteln die wir als Politikerinnen und
Politiker als Abgeordnete unseres Landes
und auch als Bundesregierung haben
ich habe daher den Botschafter
eingestellt und wir haben am Montag für
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland im
Menschenrechtsrat in Genf ganz deutlich
klargestellt die iranischen Behörden
müssen ihr brutales Vorgehen gegen die
Demonstranten und Demonstranten
unverzüglich einstellen der vor der Tod
von Gina masamini und der vielen
weiteren Menschen die bei den
Demonstrationen getötet wurden gehört
dringend aufgeklärt
einem Kreis der EU-Staaten im Kreis der
EU-Staaten tue ich gerade alles dafür
dass wir Sanktionen auf den Weg bringen
können gerade jetzt ja gerade auch jetzt
wo wir weiter über das jcpoa Verhandeln
Sanktionen gegen diejenigen in Iran auf
dem Weg zu bringen die ohne Rücksicht
Frauen im Namen der Religion zu Tode
prügeln
Demonstranten erschießen
und ich sage hier auch ganz deutlich das
ist keine Einmischung in die Belange
eines anderen Landes nein hierzu hat
sich der Iran wie jedes Land auf der
Welt verpflichtet unter anderem im
Internationalen Pakt über bürgerliche
und politische Rechte
und bei allem Respekt vor kulturellen
und religiösen Unterschieden wenn die
Polizei wie es scheint eine Frau zu Tode
prügelt weil sie aus Sicht der
sittenwärter ihr Kopftuch nicht richtig
trägt dann hat das nichts aber auch gar
nichts mit Religion oder Kultur zu tun
der nächste Schritt
gesetzliches Verbrechen und es ist
wichtig dass wir heute
fraktionsübergreifend dieses Verbrechen
so klar benennen denn ja das ist
deutsche Außenpolitik das ist deutsche
Werte geleitete feministische
Außenpolitik ich möchte an dieser Stelle
aber auch deutlich sagen eine Werte
geleitete feministische Außenpolitik
bemisst sich für mich als Politikerin
nicht daran wie laut oder oft man
twittert sondern eine Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik ist oftmals mühevoll harte
Arbeit hinter den Kulissen denn es
bedeutet vor allen Dingen Strukturen
sexistische Machtstrukturen aufzubrechen
der Feige Mord Angina haasamini ist kein
Einzelfall sondern erst Ausdruck eines
Systems ein Machtsystem das auf Gewalt
gegenüber seinen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
auf Gewalt gegenüber seinen regionalen
Nachbarn im Zweifel auch mit
Nuklearwaffen aber eben auch auf einem
System von Erniedrigung und von Gewalt
gegenüber Frauen basiert und diese
machtsysteme die finden wir wo sexuelle
Gewalt ein Teil dieses macht und
erniedrigungssystem ist leider auch an
anderen Orten dieser Welt
bei diesen Machtsystem in der Rente ist
dass Sie wissen wenn Frauen nicht sicher
sind dann weiß jeder in einem Land das
niemand sicher ist und umgekehrt gilt
wenn Frauen sicher sind dann ist jeder
sicher in einer Gesellschaft und in
diesem Sinne lieber unionskolleginnen
danke ich auch für Ihren Brief den 19
von ihnen für mich geschrieben haben und
zu mehr Einsatz für Frauenrechte
auffordern ich nehme ihnen als Ausdruck
dessen liebe Frau Güler liebe Frau schön
liebe Frau Klöckner und die anderen dass
ihre Partei dass ihre Parteivorsitzende
seiner Aussage zum sozialtourismus nicht
nur korrigiert hat sondern dass die
Union uns alle gemeinsam dabei aktiv
unterstützt das feministische
Außenpolitik mehr ist als nur eine kurze
empathische Geste dass wir gemeinsam so
wie bei dieser aktuellen Stunde bereit
sind Strukturen zu verändern auch bei
uns
dass sich die Frauen in Iran ebenso wie
die ukrainischen Frauen darauf verlassen
können dass unsere Solidarität trägt
auch wenn sie uns selbst etwas
abverlangt dass Sie sich darauf
verlassen können dass unsere Solidarität
trägt wenn diese Frauen nicht mehr
überall in den Nachrichten sind sondern
dass wir gemeinsam froh und ich würde
für mich persönlich sagen auch stolz
darauf sind dass wir nicht nur zu Beginn
dieses furchtbaren russlandkrieges diese
Flüchtlinge wie manche sie nennen
aufgenommen haben sondern dass wir Sie
mit offenen Armen empfangen haben dass
wir unsere Gesellschaft für
Hunderttausende Europäerinnen aus der
Ukraine und auch unsere Sozialsysteme
geöffnet haben weil nur so können und
konnten Kommunen Lehrer Nachbarn
Familien von Tag eins alles dafür tun
dass 4
65.00054 Frauen und
352.467 Kinder zum heutigen Tag ein
Stück Sicherheit aber eben auch ein
Stück zu Hause bekommen haben und ich
sage an dieser Stelle ganz deutlich
bei feministische Außenpolitik mehr ist
als Einzelfälle ja es hilft all diesen
Frauen und Kindern so wie es allen
anderen hilft die Schutz bei uns suchen
Kontakt nach Hause zu halten mich lässt
ein Satz in diesem Krieg nicht mehr los
ein Satz seines Mädchens das elf Jahre
alt ist in einer Schule in Potsdam die
meinte bei einem der Schulbesuche zu mir
Frau bärbox sie kennen noch Herrn
silensky können Sie ihm bitte sagen ich
möchte meinem Papa wiedersehen
und ich war so froh als ich diesen
Sommer hörte dass sie für drei Wochen in
Ukraine fuhr um ihren Vater nach 176
Tagen endlich wieder in die Arme zu
nehmen aber nichts hat mich ehrlich
gesagt mehr erleichtert als ich gehört
habe dass sie zurückgekommen ist mit
ihrer Mutter und ihrem einjährigen
Bruder weil ihr zu Hause ist die Oblast
saporica und nicht alles ist derzeit
besetzt aber es ist an der Frontlinie
und ja hunderttausende werden hin und
her Reisen zwischen der Ukraine und
Deutschland bis ihr Land wieder in die
Frieden leben kann und wir werden ihn
unsere Unterstützung geben solange sie
sie brauchen weil das bedeutet für mich
feministische Außenpolitik auch dann
solide Solidarität zu zeigen wenn der
Wind einem entgegengeht das gilt für
unsere ukrainischen Nachbarn und dann
fragen Sie warum rede ich über die
Ukraine weil die Frauen im Iran müssen
sich darauf verlassen können dass wir
nicht nur jetzt an ihrer Seite stehen
werden auch morgen und übermorgen wenn
der Wind sich bei Ihnen oder auf der
Welt weiter gedreht hat unsere
Solidarität gilt für die Frauen in
Afghanistan in Belarus und im Iran denn
so furchtbar der Tod von gieren und die
Niederschlagung der Proteste im Iran ist
das ist kein Einzelfall Gina Maser
armini du bist nicht gestorben dein Name
ist Aufruf und zwar weltweit dankeschön
die bundesaußenministerin Annalena
baerbock die hier zu Beginn dieser
aktuelle Stunde den Ton gesetzt hat und
die den Blick noch über den Iran hinaus
geweitet hat Anna-Lena baerbock hat sich
erneut Sanktionen gegen den Iran
gefordert neue Sanktionen und im Kreis
der EU wird sie und
wird sie anschieben dann eben über
weitere Konsequenzen zu sprechen jetzt
Annette wiedmann-maut für die
Unionsfraktion
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen lieber
sterben wir als dass wir weiterhin die
Erniedrigung ertragen zu diesem
existenziellen Schluss kommen Frauen im
Iran trotz Festnahmen Schlägen und
brutaler Gewalt des Mullah geschims
riskieren tausende von ihnen gerade
alles ihr Leben ihre Existenz und diese
Frauen
verdienen unsere volle Solidarität und
Sie verdienen ein starkes Zeichen der
Geschlossenheit
ihre
Stimmen sind viel zu laut als das hier
überhört oder nur kleinlaut zur Kenntnis
genommen werden können denn wenn sie den
Mut haben auf die Straße zu gehen dann
dürfen doch gerade wir die wir in
Freiheit leben zu dem Schicksal von
masseamini dem Verschwinden von Milo
farhamedi die ihr Schicksal aufdeckte
oder der Inhaftierung von mehr als
1.200 Menschen wieder
Frauenrechtsaktivistin Phase Haschemi
nicht schweigen
das aber der Bundeskanzler in seiner
15-minütigen Rede vor den Vereinten
Nationen die Proteste im Iran nicht mit
einem einzigen Satz angesprochen hat es
wirklich mehr als beschämend er hätte
gerade die Anwesenheit von
staatspräsiden
t reicht die
massivurteilen er hätte sich hinter die
vn-men Menschenrechtsdeklaration und
damit an die Seite der Protestierenden
Frauen und Männer stellen können ganz
nach dem Motto you never walk alone aber
was hat tat er schwieg wieder einmal und
sein nachgeschobener Tweet sorry der war
dann anbelanglosigkeit nicht mehr zu
überbieten und Frau verehrte Ministerin
leider waren auch Sie zu diesem Thema
bis zum heutigen Tag öffentlich kaum
wahrnehmbar das steht in deutlichem
Widerspruch zu ihrem feministischen
Anspruch aber vor allen Dingen zu den
Erwartungen der
Frauenrechtsorganisationen unter
iranischen Zivilgesellschaft warum
eigentlich bei der Ukraine sind sie viel
empathischer und sie zeigen es und auch
bei Herrn la France finden Sie doch
sonst auch klare und deutliche Worte
das Schicksal von Maser Amina hier
zahlen im Iran im übrigen unzählige
Frauen die Tag für Tag in den Händen von
Sittenpolizei und Geheimdienst gefangen
verschleppt infaktiert vergewaltigt und
getötet werden mit dem abschreifen des
Hijab mit dem Abschneiden ihrer Haare
zeigen sie der Welt und sie zeigen vor
allen Dingen ihre Stärke sie zeigen ihre
Kraft sie zeigen wie ihren unbändigen
Drang nach Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung
ihr Protest ist ein Akt der Rebellion
des sich auflehnens gegen ein
islamistischen Gottesstaat gegen ein
System der Willkür und der Unterdrückung
Frauen sind die treiben die Kraft in
diesem Kulturkampf für gesellschaftliche
Veränderung die Brutalität und die Härte
mit der das Regime gegen sie vorgeht
zeigt wie sehr Despoten Frauen fürchten
die ihre Stimmen erheben und für ihre
Rechte kämpfen egal ob hier waren ob in
Afghanistan oder in Belarus ihr
Widerstand ist der Kampf für Freiheit
und Selbstbestimmung an der ganzen
Gesellschaft
und frauenaußenpolitik ist deshalb auch
kein Rand und kein Nischenthema oder wie
oft auch gern gesagt wird es gibt doch
gerade wichtigeres nein es geht schon
längst nicht mehr darum ob wir eine
Frauen aus dem Politik brauchen nein es
geht darum mit welchen Instrumenten sie
auch wirksam wird nicht nur langfristig
sondern auch ganz konkret in akuten
Krisen und Konflikten welche Folgen
haben denn jetzt die Proteste für die
deutsche und für die europäische Politik
gegenüber dem Iran da habe ich wenig
gehört welche Konsequenzen haben Sie
denn jetzt für die Bundesregierung bei
den Verhandlungen um das nuklearabkommen
was bedeutet
frauenaußenpolitik ganz konkret im
Rahmen der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie wenn Frauen
Außenpolitik zu unserer außenpolitischen
DNA gehören soll dann muss sie doch auch
mit den Mitteln der klassischen
Außenpolitik verzahnt werden was ist
jetzt zu tun wir müssen den Druck auf
den Iran erhöhen und ihm die Ressourcen
entziehen die das unterdrückungsregime
am Laufen halten es reicht einfach nicht
wie es die EU getan hat nur den Umgang
mit den Protesten zu kritisieren zu
ihren Ursachen dann aber höflich zu
schweigen deshalb müssen zusätzlich die
Sanktionen verschärft und ausgeweitet
werden erstens ging die Personen und
Regierungsstellen die für die Morde und
des brutale Vorgehen verantwortlich sind
zweitens mit der Ausweitung auf
strategisch wichtige Felder die USA
haben bereits im Bereich von Firmen
sanktioniert die Russland mit Drohnen
beliefern die in der Ukraine eingesetzt
werden und drittens mit Nachjustierung
im digitaltechnologischen Bereich dort
wo nehme ich ansonsten die Scheinwerfer
auf das Unrecht ausgehen die
Mobilisierung und die Kommunikation der
Zivilgesellschaft erschwert wird
wir müssen alle Mittel und Wege nutzen
die Frauenrechtsbewegung im Iran zu
unterstützen dazu braucht es auch mehr
finanzielle Mittel für die regionale
Vernetzung und gerade eben nicht die von
Ihnen vorgesehenen und geplanten
Kürzungen im Haushalt des Auswärtigen
Amtes liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zögern jetzt den Punkt sind im
Feminismus keine Option handeln sie
danach
Annette wiedmann-mauz war das hier für
die cdu/cs-fraktion
dass wir dieses ohne Zweifel sehr
wichtige und auch alle bewegende Thema
im Format einer aktuellen Stunde hier
behandeln das heißt es gibt keine
Zwischenfragen gibt keine Bemerkung und
auch keine Anrechnung überzogener
Redezeit auf die Redezeit nachfolgender
Rednerinnen und Redner der einzelnen
Fraktionen das heißt aber auch denke ich
dass wir hier respektvoll miteinander
umgehen und die verabredete Redezeit von
fünf Minuten bitte einhalten so dass ich
nicht gezwungen bin dann in den
Redefluss hier einzugreifen
ich danke Ihnen für das Verständnis das
Wort hat nun die Kollegin Gabriela
Heinrich für die SPD-Fraktion die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sie haben Angst vor meinem Haar sie
haben Angst vor meiner Stimme sie haben
Angst vor meinem Körper ich als Frau
kann ein ganzes Regime verängstigen
das ist ein Zitat der iranischen
Journalistin Marie Aline
jetzt gerade in diesen Tagen gehen im
Iran tausende Menschen auf die Straße
sie gehen für ihre Rechte für ihre
Freiheit und für ihre Selbstbestimmung
auf die Straße und allen voran die
Frauen die auf offener Straße ihre
Schleier verbrennen für uns
unvorstellbar riskieren Sie dabei Leib
und Leben
sie nehmen es mit einem Regime auf das
mit brutaler Repression reagiert weit
über 1000 Menschen wurden festgenommen
ungefähr 60 wurden getötet und das sind
nur die ungefähren staatlichen Angaben
in Wahrheit sind die Zahlen wohl viel
höher und all diesen mutigen Frauen und
Männern muss und gilt unsere volle
Solidarität
[Applaus]
die Menschen im Iran sind wütend
Massa armini musste mit nur 22 Jahren
sterben und ihr Tod war der Anlass für
die aktuellen Proteste die Wurzeln der
Wut reichen aber viel tiefer es ist
nicht das erste Mal dass eine Frau von
der Sittenpolizei misshandelt wird und
es ist auch nicht das erste Mal dass auf
Proteste willkürliche Verhaftungen und
Folter folgen
und eines muss uns allen klar sein hier
geht es nicht um den hinter und ob er
falsch saß hier geht es auch nicht um
Religion hier geht es um Kontrolle über
die Körper über die Selbstbestimmung und
über die Freiheit von Frauen und
eigentlich geht es um die Freiheit im
Iran insgesamt denn nicht nur die Frauen
wünschen sich Freiheit sondern natürlich
auch Männer und sie haben eines
gemeinsam sie wehren sich gegen die
Unterdrückung
der Zwang zum Schleier ist das
sichtbarste Symbol einer systematischen
Repression die iranische Regierung macht
ihre Macht abhängig von der
Unterdrückung von Frauen weil sie Angst
hat
sie fürchtet dass jeder Art von
Lockerungen ihre Macht gefährdet
was wir hier sehen ist der
Überlebenskampf eines Systems dass ich
schon lange selbst überlebt hat und es
ist auch der Überlebenskampf des
Patriarchats
wasseramini musste sterben weil sie eine
Frau war ihr tot macht einmal mehr
bewusst feministische und
menschenrechtsgeleitete Außenpolitik
sind eins denn nur in einer Gesellschaft
in der Menschenrechte für alle
gleichermaßen gelten kann es Frieden
kann es Sicherheit geben und das
bedeutet immer auch und vor allem
Freiheit
wir nehmen diese eklatanten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen nicht hin wir
verurteilen die schweren Verstöße gegen
Frauenrechte und die brutalen
Repressionen gehen demonstrierender
Menschen die er Recht auf
Versammlungsfreiheit wahrnehmen dürfen
nicht willkürlich inhaftiert werden
nirgendwo auf der Welt
und das müssen wir der Regierung im Iran
deutlich machen und das tun wir auch wir
fordern den Iran auf sofort eine
unabhängige Untersuchung zuzulassen um
diesen Fall restlos aufzuklären und es
ist gut das Außenminister und bärbock
das Thema in den Frauen
Menschenrechtsrat bringt mit unseren
Partnern in der EU werden wir jetzt über
weitere Konsequenzen sprechen und dazu
gehören auch gezielte Sanktionen gegen
Verantwortliche
wir signalisieren dem Iran wir stehen
fest an der Seite der Menschen die für
ihre Rechte eintreten und wir stehen
fest an der Seite der Familie Amini
dort nannte man mother die
Außenministerin hat es gesagt bei ihrem
kurdischen Namen Gina
iranische Behörden erkennen kurdische
Namen aber nicht an auch das ist ein
Werkzeug staatlicher Unterdrückung auf
dinaminis Grabstein steht du bist nicht
gestorben und sinngemäß dein Name ist
ein Symbol und ich füge hinzu ein Symbol
auch für uns für Freiheit und für
Menschenrechte vielen Dank
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Jürgen
braun für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen
nach biblischen Zeugnissen die Skyros
der zweite die unter den Babylonien
verschleppten Juden in der angestammtes
Land zurückkehren die persischen Könige
ermöglichten es Ihnen den zerstörten
Jerusalemer Tempel wieder aufzubauen und
nach den eigenen Gesetzen und geboten zu
leben nur in wenigen imperiengenossen
die Juden im Verlauf der Jahrhunderte so
große Freiheiten wie unter den Persern
man schrieb das Jahr
539 vor Christi Geburt damals gab es
keinen Islam
heute lehnt sich das stolze persische
Volk Erbe eines der größten Reiche der
Weltgeschichte gegen die kulturfremde
Herrschaft der Mulas auf
eine junge Frau die 22-Jährige machste
Amini wird vor zwei Wochen auf den
straßenteerrans von der sogenannten
Sittenpolizei verhaftet nicht weil sie
keinen Kopftuch getragen hat nein sie
wurde verhaftet weil sie nicht das
richtige Kopftuch getragen haben soll
sie soll abgeführt und zu einem
sogenannten Orientierungskurs gebracht
worden sein später wird sie mit inneren
Blutungen ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert
zwei Tage darauf ist sie tot bei den
anschließenden Protesten in etlichen
Städten werden mehr als 70 weitere
Menschen getötet hunderte misshandelt
von den brutalen heschern der Mullahs
diese Toten haben eine Vorgeschichte sie
führt direkt ins Herz der europäischen
Linken als der ayatolla comeni in einem
Pariser Vorort im Exil saß pilgerten
linke 68er in Scharen zu ihm sie machten
ihn erst bekannt comeni kehrte nach der
Flucht des letzten Schah in den Irans
zurück er schaltete seine liberalen und
sozialistischen Konkurrenten aus Kombis
macht Ergreifung ist eine der größten
Katastrophen des letzten Jahrhunderts
Exil Iraner sind entsetzt über das
deutsche Verhalten gegenüber dem Islam
Löschung islamkritischer Postings voka
radikal-feminismus transportaganda und
währenddessen werden im Iran Frauen und
Schwule von Islamisten umgebracht Zitat
mit eurem Selbst hören Sie bitte den
Menschen aus dem Iran zu mit eurem
selbstgerechten Einsatz gegen die
vermeintliche Islamophobie und er stützt
ihr nur die Sklavenhalter und Peiniger
unserer Heimat so der Weckruf einer
jungen exiliranerin in Cicero
die grüne Regierungspartei sollte
angesichts der aktuellen protestet den
Mund nicht voll nehmen es war der
erzgrüne Joschka Fischer der in der
linksradikalen Zeitschrift
pflasterstrand die Islamische Revolution
mit den Worten pries sie richte sich
gegen das Eindringen des kommunistischen
des konsumistischen das Eindringen des
konsumistischen Atheismus der westlichen
Industriegesellschaft dersel
be J als Außenminister die noch immer in
den Köpfen der Linken dümpel des
Schnapsidee eines unwürdigen
atomabkommens mit diesem Staat
vorangetrieben hat und es war die
damalige grüne Vorsitzende Claudia Roth
eine selbst ernannte Feministin die den
iranischen Botschafter mit High Five
begrüßt hat nämlich es trifft auf die
SPD zu ihr Bundespräsident Steinmeier
verschickte im Namen seiner Landsleute
Glückwunsch Telegramme anlässlich des
Jahrestags der islamischen Revolution
in Artikel 3 der iranischen Verfassung
wird eine Außenpolitik auf der Grundlage
der islamischen Maßstäbe vorgeschrieben
und wie diese Werte gebundene
Außenpolitik aussieht das wissen wir zur
Genüge die Islamische Republik war
niemals auch nicht unter den
vermeintlich gemäßigten Reformen um
rohani eine
stabilitätsgarant für die Region sie war
und ist im Gegenteil der wichtigste
Finanzier von Tod und Terror im Nahen
Osten
nachdem sich die Mullahs den
benachbarten Irak unter den Nagel
gerissen hatten setzten sie ihren
Einfluss ein um islamistische Milizen im
Jemen und den Gasern mit Geld und Waffen
zu versorgen seit Neuestem liefert der
Iran kamikazedonen nach Russland die
Shahid heißen ein Shahid dass das ein
Kämpfer des Jihad Shahid bedeutet nichts
anderes als
Selbstmordattentäter sie waren ja sehr
erfolgreich und zwar Verhinderung des
des Islamismus und Terrorismus von Cador
mit ihren
is-sympathisanten die bei ihnen gelernt
haben ja super ja Frau kador sie gerade
sie gerade tut mir leid ja sie gerade
müssen jetzt sollten mal lieber
schweigen zu dem Thema Shahid bedeutet
nichts anderes als Selbstmordattentäter
und etliche iranische Politiker und
Generäle leugnen nicht einmal Israel
vernichten zu wollen die Bundesregierung
kann sich nicht mehr herausreden dass
die Menschen im Iran auf die Straße auf
der Straße sterben hat sehr wohl mit den
Frauen und menschenverachtende Islam zu
tun und es hat auch mit den jahrelangen
Beschwichtigung von links zu tun vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
im Deutschen Bundestag sitzen unter
anderem zwei Abgeordnete die gerade auch
nebeneinander sozusagen saßen in den
Reihen hier der Abgeordneten die Regie
hat das schon mal eingefangen das ist
nämlich ein Hesse mit iranischen Wurzeln
das ist auch mit nuripur der
Parteivorsitzende der Grünen und es ist
ein Rheinländer mit iranischen Wurzeln
der jetzt ans Rednerpult geht das ist
nämlich der Generalsekretär der FDP
bijanji
meine Damen und Herren
Massa Amini eine
22-jährige junge Frau wurde von der
iranischen Sittenpolizei ermordet eine
junge Frau die ihr ganzes Leben vor sich
hatte wurde mit Gewalt aus dem Leben
gerissen
schuld daran ist ein Regime das
Menschenrechte mit Füßen tritt und die
eigene Bevölkerung ohne Rücksicht auf
Verluste unterdrückt
heute sehen wir auf den Straßen
iranischer Städte mutige Frauen und
Männer die sich aus den Fesseln dieses
grausamen Regimes lösen wollen für ihren
Kampf für Menschenrechte
Bürgerrechte und Freiheit riskieren sie
ihr Leben
ihr Mut
erweckt die Hoffnung dass der
Zusammenbruch der schreckenherrschaft
der Islamischen Republik möglich ist es
ist gut dass der Deutsche Bundestag
in einer aktuellen Stunde über die
Ereignisse im Iran öffentlich diskutiert
wir hatten gestern eine wunderbare
Demonstration gehabt am Brandenburger
Tor und ich kann nur hier wiederholen
was ich auch dort gesagt habe
Solidarität und warme Worte reichen
nicht mehr aus
der Tod der Tod der 22-jährigen Massa
armini hat uns auf tragische Weise vor
Augen geführt dass wir eine fundamental
andere Iran-Politik brauchen meine Damen
und Herren
während wir während wir gestern hier im
Deutschen Bundestag im Plenum diskutiert
haben haben iranische Drohnen die
Drohnen der Revolutionswächter zivile
Ziele in der autonomen Region Kurdistans
Irak angegriffen europa braucht eine
neue Iran Strategie wir können nicht
ständig
wir können nicht ständig nur über ein
atomabkommen reden während gleichzeitig
im Iran seit vielen vielen Jahren
eklatante
Menschenrechtsverletzungen stattfinden
meine Damen und Herren viel zu lange ist
Europäische Union mit dem Iran einen
naiven Kuschelkurs Gefahren viel zu
lange wurde zu eklatanten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen immer und
immer wieder geschwiegen mit dieser
beschämende Haltung muss ein für alle
mal ein Ende haben meine Damen und
Herren
die Islamische Republik die Islamische
Republik ist ein Feind unseres
westlichen Wertesystems
dieses molaregime wird mit aller Härte
seine eigene Interessen verfolgen es
hemmt den Nano und Mittleren Osten in
seiner Entwicklung bedroht die Existenz
Israels und widerspricht jeglichem
Verständnis von Freiheit und Demokratie
die Islamische Republik Iran ist nicht
nur für eklatante
Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Iran
verantwortlich sondern auch für
Menschenrechtsverletzungen außerhalb des
Irans Deutschland
Deutschland und die Europäische Union
müssen gegenüber der Islamischen
Republik selbstbewusst und entschlossen
auftreten eine Neuausrichtung der
iran-strategie muss jetzt erfolgen um
den Druck zu erhöhen müssen wir
personenbezogene Sanktionen gegen
Vertreter des Regimes und
Revolutionswächter offen adressieren
und Frau Ministerin ich habe sehr
aufmerksam zugehört was Sie gesagt haben
und ich finde sie haben heute exakt die
richtigen Worte gefunden und ich bin
Ihnen sehr dankbar für Ihre Rede denn
dahin geht auch die Reise die Führung
der islamische Republik muss wissen dass
die Weltöffentlichkeit nichts vergisst
alle verantwortliche
alle Verantwortlichen
alle Verantwortlichen die im Namen
dieses islamistischen Regimes Verbrechen
begehen müssen für ihre Handlungen zu
Rechenschaft gezogen werden meine Damen
und Herren die Freiheit
die Freiheit im Iran liegt heute in den
Händen von mutigen Menschen die ihr
Leben riskieren auf ihren Schultern ruht
die Hoffnung auf eine bessere Zukunft in
Iran im Namen und Mittleren Osten und
auf der ganzen Welt meine Damen und
Herren
ich muss den 1987 den Iran verlassen das
ist inzwischen das auch schon ein paar
Tage her dass inzwischen 35 Jahre her
ich war damals 11 Jahre alt ich habe mit
meinen eigenen Augen Krieg und
Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Iran
gesehen
wer am eigenen Leib erfahren hat wie
sich Unfreiheit anfühlt wird sich
tagtäglich und unter allen Umständen für
Freiheit einsetzen das kann ich Ihnen an
dieser Stelle vergeben
der Name massa armini steht in diesen
Stunden stellvertretend vor den für den
vorstlosen Kampf gegen Ideologie
Ideologie gesteuerte und willkürliche
Unterdrückung meine Damen und Herren
das sind nicht die üblichen
Demonstrationen und streikt die wir
derzeit im Iran Erleben der Iran steht
heute am Rande einer Revolution und das
mularegime der Islamischen Republik am
Rande des Zusammenbruchs vielen Dank
der eindringliche Appell hier von vidjan
gear Saray
Generalsekretär der FDP der auch hier im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss des Bundestages
sitzt der gestern auch gesprochen hat
bei einer der zahlreichen Kundgebungen
in Berlin muss man sagen die größte
davon am Brandenburger Tor wo es eben
unter anderem darum ging Solidarität
auch mit der Frauenbewegung gerade im
Iran zu zeigen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren seit Tagen demonstrieren im Iran
Bürgerinnen und Bürger allen voran sehr
mutige und Frauen sehr mutige Frauen und
Mädchen gegen das theokratische Regime
des Landes sie gehen auf die Straße
gegen die Repression der ayatollas gegen
den Brutalität der Sittenwächter für
ihre Freiheit und Menschenrechte
die Ermordung der Kurdin Gina Massa
Amini hat zu landesweiten Protesten
geführt die blutig niedergeschlagen
werden mindestens 76 Tote und über 1.500
Verhaftungen gibt es schon diese
Staatsgewalt verurteilen wir auf
Schärfste
wir bekommen nur einen Bruchteil der
Geschehnisse mit weil die Medien und das
Internet im Iran eingeschränkt bzw
gleichgeschaltet sind die Gewaltexzesse
gegen friedliche Demonstrationen müssen
aber unverzüglich beendet werden jeder
einzelne Todesfall muss von den Behörden
aufgeklärt werden dafür brauchen wir
eine unabhängige internationale
Untersuchungskommission eine
UN-Menschenrechtskommission mit
zivilenvertreterinnen die diese ganzen
Fälle untersuchen müssen das fordern auf
die AktivistInnen und die
Zivilgesellschaft und die NGOs vor Ort
ich finde es gut dass in Deutschland und
in anderen Ländern viele Menschen auf
die Straße gehen um sich mit den mutigen
Frauen im Iran zu solidarisieren als
Bundestagsabgeordnete mit kurdischer
Migrationsgeschichte weiß sich wie
wichtig Solidarität in solchen Zeiten
sind die deutsche Realpolitik führt
unter der Ampelkoalition weiterhin einen
Kuschelkurs gegenüber Autokratien
gegenüber dem mulla-regime das Frauen
unterdrückt gegen nur Erdogan der
koordinieren mit chemischen Waffen
bekämpft gegenüber den Saudis die in
jenen jahrelang Zivilisten bombardiert
haben Erdogan möchte man als NATO
Verbündeten nicht verlieren außerdem
soll er ja die Flüchtlinge aus Europa
fernhalten
Saudi-Arabien ist wichtiger
Energielieferant und bei dem mularisimi
Meran fürchtet man eine Gefährdung der
Neuauflage des atomabkommens im Großen
und Ganzen geht das hier wieder um
Profite und geostrategische Interessen
aber so darf es nicht weitergehen
die mutigen Frauen im Iran brauchen
unsere Solidarität Frau berborg hat nach
ihrem amttritt eine feministische
hauspolitik angekündigt auch wenn sie
von Kriegsmüdigkeit inzwischen sprechen
in ihrer Außenpolitik wäre es jetzt
zeigt dass sie unter Beweis stellen wie
sie es auch wirklich mit den Feminismus
meinen handeln sie endlich
meine Damen und Herren die Repression
des Regimes in Teheran sind auf einem
Höhepunkt Ernest die International hat
recherchiert dass im ersten Jahr halb im
ersten Halbjahr 2022 im Iran mindestens
251 Menschen hingerichtet wurden oftmals
nach grob unfairen Gerichtsverfahren
tausende Menschen wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren strafrechtlich
verfolgt und willkürlich inhaftiert
deshalb brauchen wir Schutz und Aufnahme
für Menschen die vor dem Regime im Iran
fliehen
derzeit liegt die schutzquote bei den
Asylverfahren von Iranerinnen lediglich
bei 30 Prozent und stellen Sie sich mal
vor laut taz hatte die bayerische
Polizei in einem Fall einer Iranerin das
Kopftuch aufgezwungen um sie
ordnungsgemäß abschieben zu können
2017 meinte das Verwaltungsgericht
Nürnberg dass die Strafverfolgung im
Iran wegen Verstoßes gegen
Kleidervorschriften nicht asylrelevant
sei das habe keine politische Bedeutung
mich macht sowas einfach fassungslos
angesichts der Entwicklung im Iran
die geschlechtsspezifische Unterdrückung
von Frauen im Iran muss hier in
Deutschland als Asylgrund anerkannt
werden und es darf keine Abschiebungen
in den Iran geben
meine Damen und Herren die aktuellen
Proteste im Iran hatten in der Provinz
Kurdistan rochylat ihren Anfang und
haben sich im gesamten Land verbreitet
ich möchte auch noch mal daran erinnern
dass es die mutigen kurdischen
fraueneinheiten der jepudget sind die in
der gesamten Region für die Befreiung
der frauenkämpfen und große Opfer
bringen die Parole der kurdischen
Frauenbewegung shinjian Azadi übersetzt
Frauen Leben Freiheit hat weltweit an
Zuspruch gefunden unter diesem Slogan
liegen legen Frauen ihre Kopftücher ab
und schneiden sich aus Protest die Haare
weil sie zeigen wollen sie wollen leben
sie wollen ihn Freiheit und
selbstbestimmt leben ich bin beeindruckt
vom Kampf meiner Schwester im Iran und
den Kurdistan und möchte Ihnen meine
internationalistischen und
feministischen Grüße senden vielen Dank
ja und diesem Slogan den
noch mal genannt hat das kurdische was
sie auch auf ihrem T-Shirt vorne
aufgedruckt hatte ist kurdisch für
Frauen Leben Freiheit und das nutzen
auch die Demonstranten im Iran
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
Hadis
hat
letzte Woche eine Demonstration besucht
im Tera hat dies ist eine junge Frau
die auf die Demonstration gegangen ist
weil sie es nicht mehr ausgehalten hat
dass die Verhältnisse so sind wie sie
sind und weil sie protestieren wollte
gegen die Ermordung von Gina massamini
hat diesen hat auf dem Weg zu der
Demonstration noch eine Videobotschaft
hinterlassen für eine Freundin die sagt
ich bin nervös weil alle wissen was
denjenigen die protestieren blüht aber
die Sache ich bin froh dass ich da
hingehe weil jetzt protestieren wir und
hoffentlich ändert sich darüber in ein
paar Jahren was in diesem Land und wir
können wieder atmen wenige Stunden
später ist sie tot sechs Kugeln hatte
sie in ihrem Körper sie wurde einfach
niedergeschossen
das was da passiert ist nicht neu dass
die Rechte der Frauen im Iran
unterdrückt werden ist uralt und seit 43
Jahren wird das auch noch staatlich
organisiert
dass Leute auf die Straße gehen und
protestieren ist nicht neu wir gehen auf
die Straße wegen der Unterdrückung der
Frau wegen Korruption wegen
Luftverschmutzung wegen fehlender Rechte
von Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern wegen
gefälschter Wahlen und die Antwort des
Regimes ist seit Jahrzehnten immer nur
dieselbe das ist die rohe Gewalt und das
ist der Grund warum jetzt die Leute auf
die Straße gehen gegen das gesamte
Regime neu ist auch nicht dass Frauen
die Proteste tragen neu ist dass sie sie
jetzt anführen und vor diesem
unglaublichen Mut dieser Frauen die vor
Sicherheitsleuten mit einer Knarre in
der Hand das Kopftuch ziehen und ihn ins
Gesicht schreien dass sie sich das nicht
mehr bieten lassen kann man nur auf die
Knie fallen
und es ist auch nicht neu dass wir in
diesem Hohen Hause uns leider mit diesen
Missständen im Iran beschäftigen müssen
wir haben letztendliches naturperiode
einen Antrag initiiert als Grüne und ich
bin sehr dankbar gewesen dass wir
bekommen haben einen Zustimmung und
einen gemeinsamen Antrag der der großen
Koalition der FDP Union der Grünen und
der Menschenrechtsausschuss hat auch
diese Woche ein gemeinsamen Beschluss
gefasst einer sehr klaren Verurteilung
auch dafür ein riesen Dank haben leider
nicht alle zugestimmt ich weiß will
nicht wissen warum aber unbenommen davon
ist das natürlich unser aller Aufgabe
jetzt diesen Leuten diesen mutigen
Frauen beizustehen und was man jetzt im
Iran lernen kann ist nicht nur
inspirierend für alle die Demokratie
verteidigen weil die uns zeigen was
Freiheit und Demokratie Wert ist Kollege
gius hat völlig darauf zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen dass Leute die Unfreiheit
erlebt haben denn wissen was Freiheit
wert ist und ich kann nur hoffen dass
man nicht erst diese Erfahrung machen
muss um dieser Wertigkeit auch zu kennen
aber was wir gerade im Iraner Leben ist
ja dass die Männer begreifen da wo
Frauenrechte unter die Räder kommen
kommen Menschenrechte aller unter die
Rede und deshalb gehen sie mit auf die
Straße und deshalb
und deshalb
bin ich so dankbar dass die
Außenministerin nicht nur sich dieser
Tage sich mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
und sich darum kümmert dass der Druck
erhöht wird ich bin nicht nur dankbar
dass die feministische Außenpolitik in
den Mittelpunkt ihrer Politik auch rückt
und bei jeder Reise ist das ein großes
Thema das ist ja glaube ich für alle die
sehen wollen noch sehr sichtbar ich bin
noch dankbar weil so viele Leute in
diesem Land das sehen sich davon
berühren lassen und das machen worum die
Frauen im Iran bitte nicht persönlich
geht hier einigen so so hab so viele
Zuschriften bekommen so viele Posts
bekommen von Frauen nicht nur aber vor
allem von Frauen die sagen gerade jetzt
wo das Internet abgestellt wird sei
meine Stimme seit meine Stimme und wir
haben bei aller Notwendigkeit Druck zu
machen in politischen Raum bei aller
Notwendigkeit institutionell im
EU-Rahmen alles dafür zu tun damit auch
weitere Sanktionen beschlossen werden
wegen der Lage vor Ort haben auch die
Verpflichtung alles dafür zu tun damit
diese mutigen Frauen nicht vergessen
werden denn die internationale
Aufmerksamkeit
denn dieser internationale
Aufmerksamkeit die wir hier bringen die
wir aufbringen müssen ist sehr oft der
einzige Schutz denn dieser Frauen haben
und dieser ermutigt sie auch die gehen
natürlich aus purer Verzweiflung auf die
Straße ohne Angst weil sie diese Angst
verloren haben nach all den rückfliegen
der letzten Jahre aber sie wollen
natürlich auch gesehen werden weil sie
wissen dass sie nicht alleine sind und
dieses Gefühl müssen wir aufrecht halten
denn das ist ein Baustein vielleicht ein
kleiner aber der eine Baustein den wir
geben können damit das was hat Diesner
Jacky sich gewünscht hat am Ende des
Tages auch kommt nämlich Veränderungen
das Regime selbst ist zu Reformen schon
lange nicht mehr zwischen imstande das
ist Zeit dass die Bevölkerung das jetzt
macht und dafür sollten wir ihnen
beistehen
war das der Parteivorsitzende der Grünen
und als er hier auch noch mal sagte vor
dem Mut der Frauen kann man nur auf die
Knie fallen da gab es viel Applaus hier
im Haus nicht nur von den
ampelfraktionen auch beispielsweise von
Abgeordneten aus der CDU CSU-Fraktion
auch von Abgeordneten der Linksfraktion
also hier ein Signal was man auch senden
will in den ihrer an Dorothee Bär jetzt
für die Union
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer ich finde es
gut dass wir uns heute im Deutschen
Bundestag mit dem Thema beschäftigen
dass wir nicht nur so wie gestern
draußen bei den Demonstrationen bei den
Kundgebungen darüber sprechen sondern
eben auch hier im Deutschen Bundestag im
Parlament wo es hingehört dass wir hier
auch der Lage der iranischen Frauen
gedenken warum
weil wir gestern viele weil wir gestern
überparteilich erst beim deutschen
Frauenrat am Nachmittag auch bei Hawa
hält bei unterschiedlichen
Veranstaltungen waren und weil wir
einfach gespürt haben das was eben auch
schon angesprochen wurde dass wir auf
Demonstrationen haben gehen können dass
wir skandieren konnten dass wir die
Geschichten nacherzählen konnten und das
aber uns ein unterscheidet zu den Frauen
im Iran unsere Demonstrationen gestern
haben natürlich überhaupt keinen Mut
erfordert es ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit in unserem Land
auf die Straße zu gehen für uns alle es
ist eine Selbstverständlichkeit auch auf
diese Demonstrationen zu gehen so wie
wir sehen so wie wir gekleidet sein
wollen und deswegen möchte ich auch im
Namen unserer Fraktion noch mal wirklich
ganz ganz herzlich all den mutigen
Frauen danken und die Geschichten wurden
ja erzählt die eben wenn Sie auf eine
Demonstration gehen nicht wissen ob sie
abends wieder nach Hause kommen
und wir
wir wissen wir alle die wir heute hier
sind kennen die Geschichte von China
Massa Amini aber ich möchte trotzdem
noch mal plastisch vor Augen führen sie
war mit ihrem Bruder in Teheran zu
Besuch sie wurde am 13 September von der
sogenannten Sittenpolizei festgenommen
weil er hitschert ihr Kopftuch zu locker
gewesen sei man hätte ja Haare sehen
können das ist gerade für die jungen
Menschen vielleicht auf der Tribüne
unfassbar sich vorzustellen dass das ein
Grund ist jemanden zu Tode zu Foldern
wenigen Stunden später ist sie mit
schweren Kopfverletzungen ins Koma
gefallen im Polizeigewahrsam gestorben
mit 22 Jahren und wir schreiben das Jahr
wenn man sich mal überlegt wenn wir 43
Jahre zurückblicken dass das eine Zeit
wo vielleicht viele noch gar nicht die
hier jetzt im Bundestag sind auf der
Welt sind ins Jahr 1979 wurden New York
die ein Vollversammlung des
Übereinkommen zur Beseitigung jeder Form
von Diskriminierung der Frau
verabschiedet hat die sogenannte
frauenrechtskonvention wenn wir
überlegen dass natürlich der Iran keiner
der 186 Staaten ist die das ganze
ratifiziert haben wenn man überlegt dass
1979 auch eben dieses theokratische
System das Land beherrscht dann hoffe
ich dass wirklich der Tod von China
Massa ein Mini dazu beiträgt dass diese
Regime endlich gebrochen werden kann
[Applaus]
und es sind nicht nur die brutalsten
Handlungen der Unterdrückung die wir
jetzt sehen warum hat es ganze das jetzt
ausgelöst weil es gesehen wird weil es
Bilder gibt es ja nicht der erste Fall
und kein Einzelfall sondern die
iranische Justiz rechtfertigt für
freiheitliche Nationen auch
unvorstellbare Grollen es gibt
Hinrichtungen von Frauen es gibt
Steinigungen es gibt Ehrenmorde es gibt
Folter es gibt Missbrauch häusliche
Gewalt Kinderehen das gehört alles zum
Alltag im Iran das heißt
Frauenfeindlichkeit per Gesetz wir
Menschen kämpfen für die Freiheit für
ihre Rechte für die Rechte der Frauen
aber ehrlicherweise nicht nur für die
Rechte der Frauen auch für Menschen die
anders leben und für Menschen die anders
lieben und die Frauen die auf die Straße
gehen ihre Kopftücher verbrennen sich
ihre Haare schneiden lassen die sind
gestern auch auf uns zugekommen und
haben gesagt für unsere Verwandten vor
Ort bitte seid ihr die Stimme
seid ihr die Bilder seid ihr das
Internet was wir momentan nicht haben
und sehr geehrte Frau
bundesaußenministerin
ich persönlich aber auch viele in meiner
Fraktion finden es sehr gut dass es auch
eine feministische Außenpolitik gibt und
ich finde schon dass die feministische
Außenpolitik auch jetzt natürlich der
Lackmustest ist gerade bei den Frauen im
Iran und mir hat es schon weh getan dass
gestern auch Schilder hochgehalten
wurden bei den Demonstrationen das sind
ja auch ihre UnterstützerInnen und und
Unterstützer die Fragen wo ist denn
jetzt die feministische Außenpolitik und
Ronja Ottmann hat in der FAZ in ihrem
Brief für China geschrieben und bei all
dem Gerät über feministische
Außenpolitik wo ist die feministische
Außenpolitik wenn man sie braucht mögen
den schönen wortentaten folgen und es
unterstreiche ich da haben sie uns auch
an ihrer Seite dass es eben dringend
auch Taten geben muss dass es
personenbezogene Sanktionen gibt dass
den Sittenwächtern die im Iran
kraftamtes morden und foltern dass sie
sich nicht mehr hier aufhalten können
weil sie nicht mehr von Jens hatten
Bankkonten zehren können dass es eine
neue Iran Strategie der Bundesregierung
gibt ich möchte mich da meinem Kollegen
der FDP anschließen und ich bin dankbar
und würde mich wirklich freuen wenn Ihre
Rede auch mit zum Maßstab der
Bundesregierung werden würde dass dieses
Dröhnen der Schweigen was wir zwei
Wochen gehört haben beendet wird dann
haben sie uns an ihrer Seite ganz
herzlichen Dank Dorothee Bär war das für
die CDU CSU-Fraktion die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun dr Nils
schwittersburg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
Frau Leben Freiheit mit diesen rufen
sind viele tausend mutige Frauen auf der
Straße in vielen Städten des Irans sie
kämpfen gegen die strukturelle
Unterdrückung sie kämpfen für die
Freiheit und sie beweisen einmal mehr
und rufen uns allen auch in Deutschland
in Erinnerung
Frauenrechte sind Menschenrechte und
wenn Frauen für ihre Rechte auf die
Straße gehen kämpfen sie immer auch für
die Rechte und Freiheitsrechte der
Männer nicht nur der der Frauen sie
kämpfen für die Freiheit der
Gesellschaft für Bürgerinnen und
Bürgerrechte und deshalb ist der Zustand
der Frauenrechte immer auch der Maßstab
für den Zustand der Menschenrechte in
einer jeden Gesellschaft und in allen
lebensstaatswesen und deshalb müssen wir
leider festhalten dass der Iran
trotz aller Bemühungen Frauen
beispielsweise in Bildung und Ausbildung
nach vorne zu bringen dass der Iran die
Islamische Republik Iran strukturellen
Frauen strukturell frauenfeindlich und
damit auch strukturell
menschenrechtsfeindlich ist und deshalb
ist es auch so richtig dass die
feministische Außenpolitik so wie die
Außenministerin sie formuliert hat an
die Strukturen geht im Iran in anderen
Staaten und Gesellschaften dieser Welt
und deshalb kann ich den Vorwurf Frau
Bär auch nicht nachvollziehen es würde
ein grünes Schweigen gehen aus der
Bundesregierung sowohl der Kanzler wie
die Außenministerin haben sich klar auf
die Seite der Frauen im Iran geschlagen
und wir unterstützen Sie uneingeschränkt
[Applaus]
auf Kurdisch lautet der Ruf Jin Gian
asadi Frau Akbulut hat die
Freundlichkeit gab es sogar aufs T-Shirt
zu schreiben und hier zu präsentieren
damit ist aber auch eins angezeigt durch
diese Formulierung
der Iran ist ein vielfilterstaat und
trotz der zur Schau gestellten Toleranz
wie sie uns über regierungsmedien immer
wieder präsentiert wird
ist auch die Unterdrückung von
kulturellen rechten von sozialen rechten
Programm in der Islamischen Republik und
diese strukturelle Unterdrückung von
Vielfalt spielt eben rein in ein
strukturell freiheitsfeindliches Regime
und es ist ein Grund mehr die Freiheit
und Demokratie Bewegung im Iran voll zu
unterstützen
was heißt jetzt Unterstützung natürlich
heißt es und es sollten wir nicht gering
achten Solidarität Solidarität die wir
zum Ausdruck bringen durch die Debatte
hier im Parlament parteiübergreifen die
wir zum Ausdruck bringen in Äußerungen
bei demonstrierte Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die gasumlage ist ja gekippt
die gaspreisbremse kommt die
Bundesregierung will ein 200 Milliarden
Abwehrschirm gegen die
energiepreisbremse gegen die
Energiekrise wir hören jetzt mal den
Fraktionschef der Union sind wir wieder
im Plenarsaal und dort ist noch die
Aktuelle Stunde die die Fraktionen SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und die FDP hier
verlangt haben es geht um die Proteste
im Iran nach dem die
22-Jährige Mascha armini in Polizei
Gewahrsam gestorben ist ja am 13
September es ist noch unklar woran sie
gestorben ist allerdings wurde sie
festgenommen weil sie anscheinend so ist
der Vorwurf ihr Kopftuch richtig
getragen hat und
deswegen wurde sie wie auch andere
festgenommen und brach dann in der
Festnahme unter eben ungeklärten
Umständen zusammen drei Tage später ist
sie dann im Krankenhaus gestorben und
seitdem gibt es jeden Tag Proteste im
Iran dagegen geht die sogenannte nun
muss man das wirklich in
Anführungszeichen sagen
Sicherheitskräfte die gehen dagegen
gewaltsam vor das Internet ist gestört
und es wird hier versucht deutlich zu
unterbinden dass die Menschen sich
dagegen aussprechen und mindestens 76
Menschen wurden schon getötet so sagt
ist die nicht Regierungsorganisation
Iran Human Rights die in Oslo sitzt
darunter sollen auch Frauen und Kinder
sein und wie Deutschland reagieren kann
wie Deutschland reagieren sollte dass es
hier in Bundestag jetzt in der
Debatte die Frage und Lamia Cador
spricht dafür jetzt für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren auf den Tribünen da
oben ich bin mir eigentlich nicht
wirklich sicher ob wir heute aus dieser
aus diesem sicheren Land und dieser
sicheren Stelle in dieser sicheren
Herzkammer unserer Demokratie wirklich
nachempfinden können was uns die Bilder
aus dem Iran zeigen und ich bin auch
nicht sicher ob auch ich mir wirklich
vorstellen kann wie es sich anfühlt
wegen eines verrutschten Kopftuchs
festgenommen zu werden oder wenn meine
Tochter nach einem Spaziergang mit ihren
Freundinnen im Park nicht nach Hause
kommen würde und dann stellte sich
heraus dass ihr T-Shirt verrutscht war
sondern ein Stück ihres Rückens sichtbar
wurde und eine sogenannte
Religionspolizei die ja übrigens auch
von Frauen also in denen auch Frauen
offensichtlich der auf Frauen tätig sind
sie deshalb in Gewahrsam festhält das
ist natürlich unvorstellbar welche
Ängste Kämpfe Hoffnungen Erschütterungen
die iranische Frauen dieser Tage
durchstehen auch ich vermag ist nur zu
erahnen
trotzdem rufe ich Ihnen zu wir sehen was
hier aushaltet wir sehen wie ihr leidet
und wir sind an eurer Seite
für schlagen für schlagen Knüppeln
anbrüllen foltern und erschießen gibt es
keine Rechtfertigung nirgends niemals
egal von wem und mit welcher Begründung
daher hat urteile ich von dieser Stelle
des Hohen Hauses dem Deutschen Bundestag
das Vorgehen des iranischen Regimes auf
schärfste ich prangere seine
Menschenrechtsverletzungen an und rufe
Ihnen zu hören sie auf Frauen
anzugreifen hören sie auf ihnen das
Leben zur Hölle zu machen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Schicksal der Frauen und Mädchen rührt
uns besonders an aber es geht noch um
viel mehr nach Jahrzehnten der
Unterdrückung da müssen Wirtschaft der
Korruption durch das regimeteran ist
dieser Tage erneut ersichtlich wie groß
der Widerstand in der iranischen
Gesellschaft insgesamt ist wenn nicht
auf Linie des Regimes ist ist dagegen so
einfach stellt sich das im Moment da
nach der gewaltsamen Niederschlagung der
Proteste von 2019 setzen die Iraner und
Iraner erneut ihr Leben aufspielen in
dieser Stunde geht es für uns einerseits
darum sich mit den Menschen die im Iran
seit dem Tod der jungen Kurden Gina
massamini vor elf Tagen auf die Straße
gehen zu solidarisieren und andererseits
dem regimeteran eine eindeutige
Nachricht zukommen zu lassen nämlich die
Gewalt gegenüber Demonstranten und
Demonstranten wird Konsequenzen haben
deshalb hat unsere Außenministerin auch
jetzt gerade sehr deutlich gesagt und
gemacht den iranischen Botschafter ins
Auswärtige Amt bestellt und arbeite mit
Hochdruck an weiteren gemeinsamen
EU-Sanktionen Briefe wie der von der
Frauenunion der CDU der die Ministerin
zum Handeln aufruft sind daher doch
befremdlich denn im Grunde genommen hat
sie all das gemacht was sie gerade von
ihr verlangt haben
richtig die Außenministerin sagte und
ich zitierte sie noch mal wiederholen
Sie hiermit auch die Protest im Iran
zeigen einmal mehr warum eine
feministische Außenpolitik den
Unterschied macht denn wenn Frauen wie
Gina Massa Amini wegen unmoralischer
Kleidung nicht sicher sind dann ist
keiner in der Gesellschaft sicher und
genauso ist es du behält es sich leider
leider seit Jahrzehnten im Iran es
herrscht Willkür die selbst ernannten
Sittenwächter wollen entscheiden was
islamisch und nicht islamisch ist
Berichte von Gewaltanwendungen und
foltern Gewahrsam der angeblichen
Sittenpolizei sind die Regeln nicht die
Ausnahme das Gina Massa Amini mutmaßlich
wegen der Verhaftung durch diese Leute
verstarb überrascht niemanden es zeigt
einmal mehr dass Gewalt zu Kontrolle von
Menschen oder der Menschen für die
Anhängern des müller-regimes ein
legitimes Mittel ist ihr eigenes Ziel
eigene Macht und Privilegien erhalten
und so geht es den Demonstranten und
DemonstrantInnen eben nicht primär um
den Kopftuchzwang im Iran die manche
hier behaupten sondern die Proteste
wenden sich viel mehr gegen eine brutale
Herrschaft die zudem das Land isoliert
und durch Korruption und Kriege
heruntergewirtschaftet hat sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir können die Proteste nicht
diskutieren ohne die destabilisierende
Wirkung und Rolle des Irans in der
Region zu erwähnen im Irak im Libanon in
Syrien im Jemen unterstützt Teheran
direkt oder indirekt gewaltbereiter
Akteure sie bedrohen die Sicherheit
Israels und anderer Staaten in dieser
Region die russische Armee hat zuletzt
wenn mehr Drohnen iranischer Produktion
in der Ukraine eingesetzt auch das zeigt
deutlich dass das iranische Regime
dass das Regime noch mal dass das
iranische Regime auf Seiten des
Aggressors steht gemeinsam mit unseren
internationalen Partnern müssen wir
jetzt handeln und das aggressive
Verhalten der Mullahs führt dazu dass
wir unsere Anstrengung weiter verstärken
sollten ich möchte meine heutige rede
mit einem Zitat von gilt das sahibi
beenden sie ist Ärztin
Politikwissenschaftlerin Journalistin
und deutsche mit iranischen Wurzeln sie
stellt fest eine der weltweit größten
feministischen Protestbewegung der
vergangenen Jahrzehnte geht vom Nahen
Osten aus Isen that something darauf
kann ich nur entgegnen und deshalb
verdienen diese Frauen unsere größte
Anerkennung und Solidarität vielen Dank
[Applaus]
appelliert hier an die Abgeordneten dass
es Anerkennung und Respekt doch braucht
kriegt ihr auch noch mal eine Umarmung
von omidori PUR der hier auch schon
gesprochen hat Frank Schwabe ist der
letzte Redner in dieser aktuellen Stunde
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe der SPD-Fraktion frau
Präsidentin verehrte Damen und Herren
Herr Dr Röttgen ich weiß gar nicht ob
ihnen das aufgefallen ist sie haben ja
versucht hier irgendwie ein Popanz zu
konstruieren eine Theorie aufzustellen
die sie sozusagen sich ausgedacht haben
und selbst versucht haben hier zu
belegen als sie dann über das
nuklearabkommen gesprochen haben dachte
ich jetzt kommt er irgendwie ein
Vorschlag jetzt sagen Sie am Ende das
wir wollen Sie vielleicht auch gar nicht
mehr haben sie wollen ja schon wirklich
beides haben und sie haben dann gesagt
wir tun aber die Außenministerin und wir
alle tun zu wenig im Bereich der
Menschenrechtspolitik gegenüber dem Iran
aber ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen
aufgefallen ist mir ist es jedenfalls
aufgefallen Sie haben mir überhaupt
nicht keinen Vorschlag dazu gemacht zu
was sie eigentlich diese Bundesregierung
auffordern sondern sie haben einen
Popanz aufgebaut und ich finde das kann
nicht funktionieren weil dieser Teil des
Hauses diese Koalition beides tut die
bemüht sich um den Weltfrieden und sie
stellt aber auch die Menschenrechte in
den Mittelpunkt ihrer Außenpolitik und
das ist auch richtig so
wir gedenken heute
Gina Masa armini 22 Jahre alte
Iranerinnen und mit ihr vielen anderen
tausenden bei Protesten getöteten
Hingerichteten den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten was ist das eigentlich für
eine Regierung eines Staates die die
eigene Bevölkerung wegen einer
Kleiderordnung verhaften verprügeln und
mutmaßlich auch
totschlagen lässt weltweit und auch hier
in Deutschland erinnern wir und
unterstützen wir diese Proteste die
deutsche Bevölkerung aber
interessanterweise haben wir viele
Menschen die aus dem Iran zu uns
gekommen sind hier auch in der deutschen
Politik der Parteivorsitzende der Grünen
der Generalsekretär der FDP wir haben
einen fraktionsreferenten aus dem
menschenrechtsbereich Arash sarkori
und die sind ja wahrscheinlich nicht
deswegen hier weil es so toll in
Deutschland ist hier ist es auch toll
sondern das sind deswegen hier weil sie
eben nicht mehr im Iran leben konnten
und deswegen ist es kein vom Besten
gesteuerter
Protest oder keine vom Westen gesteuerte
Revolution aber es immer da kommt
sondern es ist ein Protest und der
Unterstützung eines Prozesses von einem
freien Teil der Welt da wo Iranerinnen
und Iraner ihr ihre Heimat gefunden
haben weil wir hier eben offen reden
können weil wir hier für Freiheit und
für Offenheit in der Gesellschaft stehen
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir das
hier gemeinsam alle diskutieren können
und dass wir in der Tat gemeinsam und
das sollten wir auch nicht untergraben
als Deutscher Bundestag ein klares
Signal richten wir sind an der Seite der
Iranerinnen und Iraner die dort jetzt
protestieren
und ich will erinnern an nachmittagavi
und andere die in Deutschland eigentlich
leben und beheimatet sind die aber ab
und zu im Iran sind und jetzt verhaftet
sind Neid targary seit dem 16 Oktober
des Jahres
2020 und ich will auch daran erinnern
dass iranische
Regierung von Iran geschickte
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter hier in
Deutschland nicht nur im Iran auch in
Deutschland ihr Unwesen treiben und
Menschen die hier in der Opposition sind
im Exil sind bedrängen und ich finde
dass wir alle gemeinsam auch noch mal
genauer hingucken sollten zusammen mit
den deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden ob das
eigentlich so sein kann ob wir da nicht
weiter tätig werden können
seit jetzt mittlerweile 13 Tagen eben
die Proteste nicht ab und es gibt ja
unterschiedliche Einschätzungen dazu
wie lange das geht und wie das wie das
ausgeht nach all den Erfahrungen der
letzten Jahre mein Eindruck ist
jedenfalls und das was ich geschildert
bekomme das ist so ist das anders als
2016 und 2019 jetzt alle Schichten dabei
sind
Vertreterinnen Vertreter Menschen aus
großen und kleinen Städten traditionelle
und liberale Communities und eben auch
Menschen die wir als vermutlich
unpolitisch beschreiben würden und
deswegen will ich auch an der Stelle
danken Zadar asmun und der iranischen
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft und ich finde
gerade bei der Debatte die wir rund um
Katar führen Stände ist der FIFA gut an
sich klar zur positionieren und sich mit
dieser iranischen
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer zur
solidarisieren
die Angst ist bei vielen der Mut
gewichen zum Teil den Mut der
Verzweiflung die trotz aller Erfahrungen
der brutalen Niederschlagung und 1.500
Toten
an drei Tagen 2019 jetzt auf die Straße
gehen Frauen das ist vielfach betont
worden sind die Speerspitze dieses
Protestes unter der Parole San sengeti
asadi Frau Leben und Freiheit und
deswegen ist das vielleicht ein
positiver Nebeneffekt der heutigen
Debatte hier habe dass er jetzt
verstanden dass zumindest Teile der
Unionsfraktion das Thema einer
feministischen Außen- und
Entwicklungspolitik jetzt ganz gut
finden weil es genau darum ja geht
Menschen auf der Welt die unterdrückt
sind aus unterschiedlichen Gründen die
unterdrückt sind aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen instand zu versetzen für ihre
Freiheit und für ihr Leben und für ihr
freies Leben sich entsprechend
einzusetzen und dass wir das mit aller
Kraft aus Deutschland entsprechend
unterstützen
und ein kleines Ablauf an letzter Satz
ein letzter Satz es ist ja hier von
Religion geredet worden ich finde das
muss man sich auch noch mal klar machen
es ist keine freifrage von Religion
Menschen vorzugeben wie sie zu leben
haben es gibt andere muslimische Länder
wo wir ja solche Vorschriften nicht
haben deswegen kann das schon nicht
richtig sein und ich finde das ist das
was man sowohl den mullas im Iran sagen
muss aber auch der AFD dass das keine
Frage von Religion ist wenn Menschen
wenn Frauen frei leben wollen vielen
herzlichen Dank
Frank Schwabe war das der letzte Redner
hier in dieser aktuellen Stunde zu den
Protesten nach dem Tod von marcel-amini
etwas gesagt danke all denen die mir
geholfen haben dass ich gerade in dieser
Debatte nicht in Redebeiträge
hineingehen musste um die Redezeit
entsprechend einzuklagen ich Spalte mir
noch vor sowohl verbale Äußerungen in
der Debatte als auch nonverbale
Demonstrationen und Äußerungen im
Protokoll im Video und anderswo zu
prüfen und gegebenenfalls die Dinge die
zu sanktionieren sind zu sanktionieren
aber hiermit ist erst einmal die
Aktuelle Stunde beendet